I hope you enjoyed this course and to help you complete it
I want to make sure that there are a few course resources that you know about
First if you have any questions
Or you want to discuss anything with the classmates or the teaching staff including me?
Or if you want to file a bug report the best place to do that is the discussion forum
The teaching staff and I will be modeling that regularly and this is also a good place for you to
Get answers to your questions from your classmates or if you wish try to answer your classmates questions
to get to the discussion forum from this course homepage if you look at this menu bar on the left you also might look a
Bit different than mine, but they'll do this discussion forum tab which give you click on gives you to the discussion forum?
the best way to ask questions is on the discussion forum but it for some reason you need to contact us directly or
Let us know about some problem feel free also to email us at this email address I
Promise we will read every email, and we'll try to address
commonly occurring issues although depending on the email Volume I
Can't guarantee that we'll be able to reply promptly to every email, but we will read every email that you send
Next I know that there are other companies that wish to train maybe large numbers of employees would be learning if you're responsible for
Employee training in your company and would like to train a hundred or more
employees
With deep learning expertise, please feel free to get in touch at this email, and we'll see if we can help you
we're just in the early phases of developing the university academic program, but if you're a university instructor or a
University Administrator
Interested in offering a deep learning course at your university, please feel free to contact us at this email address
so I hope that gives you more resources to complete the course maybe I'll see some of you in the discussion forums and
best of luck